la nouvelle exposition du médium
d'histoire naturelle de tour ça
s'appelle les as de la jungle
directement inspirés du dessin animé
cette animation propose aux enfants de
partir en mission avec leur personnage
préféré une façon une nouvelle fois de
les sensibiliser à la protection de
l'environnement la Turquie
mais où est
donc le gorille
ça sa recherche et compte sur les
visiteurs pour les aider dans leur quête
une mission pas si évidente mais avec
une bonne après-midi à la clé
on a fait plein de
juste la dernière où on a fait c'est
comment cet après-midi
[Musique]
pour délivrer le Singe Bleu
et on a on a réussi à trouver ah j'ai
adoré
c'était super bien une partie de Baby
graines des énigmes ou même des canons
pour repousser les pirates les as de la
jungle s'appelaient au petit et aussi au
plus grand c'est intéressant c'est
ludique pour les enfants c'est un bon
prétexte pour découvrir finalement la
jungle ça vous a intéressé aussi oui
très bien oui tout à fait même si je
connaissais pas du tout les personnages
contrairement mes petites filles qui
elles sont férus du dessin animé c'est
bien créé par le Muséum de Toulouse et
le studio d'animation français that
production l'exposition pose ses valises
à Tours pendant 4 mois c'est une
exposition qui est plutôt dédiée aux
enfants de 7 à 12 ans c'est vraiment
très interactif effectivement c'est
plutôt des petits jeux et grâce à ça on
essaye de faire passer des informations
sur la forêt tropicale sur les
différentes espèces sur les espèces en
danger surtout voilà il y a aussi un
côté
sensibilisation derrière qui est
vraiment très important
pas de réservation nécessaire pour
profiter de l'expérience et pour éviter
la foule l'idéal est de venir le matin
ou en fin de journée l'exposition des as
de la jungle et donc à retrouver au
Muséum d'histoire naturelle de Tours
jusqu'au 11 juin